chaleur sécheresse et orages avec des
températures qui se maintient autour de
35 degrés plusieurs départements restent
en vigilance sanitaire les très forts
orages qui se sont déclenchées hier dans
plusieurs régions de france et en ile de
france n'ont pas permis aux températures
de baisser durablement premiers jours de
soldes dans la moitié nord du pays à
paris c'était la ruée dans les magasins
dès l'ouverture
il est vrai qu avant les départs en
vacances les français ont voulu faire le
plein de bonnes affaires
nicolas sarkozy ne mâche pas ses mots
c'est son style et il aime fab le
ministre de l'intérieur invité de ce
journal s'expliquera sur ces formules
chocs qui suscite la polémique
et au-delà sur les actions qu'il compte
mener
dix mois après la tuerie dans une école
de beslan qui avait causé la mort de 330
personnes dont 186 enfants du commando
de trente et un terroriste il ne reste
qu'un seul survivant seul accusé
aujourd'hui dans le box pour répondre
aux questions des mères c'est une île en
baie de cannes consacrée à la prière et
la méditation saint-honorat au lard la
croisette loin des paillettes et du
culte de l'apparence abrite une
communauté de moines cisterciens
installé depuis plusieurs cycles madame
monsieur bonsoir la france à chaud les
températures sont restées
exceptionnellement élevé aujourd'hui
dépassant les 30 degrés en dépit des
fortes averses d'hier le dispositif de
veille sanitaire du plan canicule reste
d'actualité dans plusieurs départements
de l'est du pays
à paris pour le sixième jour consécutif
le seuil de pollution numéro ans a été
dépassé
enfin edf invite les français à limiter
leur consommation d'électricité en
rappelant quelques mesures de bon sens
fermer les volets le jour
vont-ils et la nuit éviter la
climatisation excessive le point sur la
situation avec laurenti c'est l'été le
soleil caressant tibet le moins que l'on
puisse dire c'est qu'elle se laisse
faire
à 18h le mercure flirte encore avec les
26 degrés on s'est pas attardé à la
sortie des bureaux de l'école à paris
non plus on n'a pas la plage évidemment
mais on a le trocadéro et ses concours
improvisé de t-shirts mouillés
c'est chaud sur les terrasses des cafés
impossible de garder une cravate même
pour une simple pause
non enfin concernant sa clientèle et
reprendre sa voiture éventuellement
cauchemar en perspective pour certains
on va pas de clim on en chie
trop chaud sorte que quoi qu on est gros
comme ça
des températures nettement au dessus des
normales saisonnières depuis huit jours
pas assez cependant pour décaler les
horaires de travail sur les chantiers du
coup il faut s'adapter et bien joué on
se rafraîchit comment comment on peut
vous envoie trois litres d'eau par jour
chaleur ils ont été donnés ainsi ses
drapés se rafraîchir les brumisateurs
des ventilateurs frais des conseils
d'une simplicité tels que les appliquer
relève du jeu d'enfant
ces fortes chaleurs ont provoqué hier
des orages très spectaculaire les masses
d'air chaudes
or tant celle plus fraîches en altitude
à paris il est tombé près de 50 litres
d'eau au mètre carré par endroits
explication de ce phénomène avec
laurence de leurs gilles jacquet et
jinan berkous paris un soir glacial de
novembre non paris hier après midi deux
jours après le début des essais 34° à
londres l'orage éclate
aucune victime mais les pompiers
interviennent à 500 reprises notamment
pour des inondations de caves
l'eau s'engouffre partout y compris dans
le métro hier il faisait chaud dans son
pays et pourtant l'orage n'a éclaté que
sur l'île de france et le nord de la
région centre une température élevée ne
suffit pas à déclencher ce phénomène
météo il faut d'abord une accumulation
d'air très chaud en basse couche c'est à
dire près du sol
c'est la première condition la deuxième
condition est qu'il faut suffisamment
d'humilité dont claire il ya
suffisamment de vapeur d'eau dans l'air
et la troisième qui est très importante
et il faut qu'ils aient de l'air froid
en altitude plus l'écart de température
entre l'altitude et le sol est important
plus leur âge et violent et puis il peut
l'air chaud plus légers mon se refroidit
et forment les nuages et mouvements
d'air engendre une accumulation de
charge électrique positive au sommet
négatives à la baguette
le seul levier positif toutes les
oppositions provoque une décharge
électrique et donc ceci des éclairs cet
après midi 15 départements du sud-est
ont été placés en alerte orange jusqu'à
demain matin météo france craint des
orages violents avec de fortes pluies
de quoi se rafraîchir encore en cours
ces précipitations n'empêche pas la
sécheresse de s'amplifier dans 28
départements l'usagé de l'eau est limité
le ministre de l'agriculture dominique
bussereau a qualifié la situation d'
exceptionnellement difficile pour les
agriculteurs
exemple dans le vaucluse où les
ressources sont n'ont jamais été aussi
basses chacun s'efforce d'économiser au
maximum le peu d'eau disponible isabelle
steiss venu un jour n'en est christophe
la jota ça c'est la partie de l'ancien
potager que où on a cultivé un peu
quelques des fraisiers des des tomates
des différents légumes des salades etc
il y a quelques années le jardin de
jean-pierre était florissant des proches
mais il est fichu quoi le fichu plus
question d'arroser pour cause de pénurie
d'eau on jette jamais l'eau inutilement
c'est à dire que dès que dans l'évier
oui on lave un petit quelque chose
et là on va jeter sur les arbres ou sur
les fleurs à cucuron dans le vaucluse
trois années de sécheresse sont
assoiffés les nappes phréatiques dans ce
quartier alimenté par des forages ont
fait des réserves pour passer l'été on
craint qu'une fois passé l'an dernier
c'est à dire que j'ai tout donné dans
les chasses données dans les douches me
lave linge intégrable dans les environs
voici la rivière qui alimente la ville
d'hama depuis mai 2004 on a une rivière
qui est dans cet état là avec quelques
passages d'eau aux différents épisodes
pluvieux qui sont qui sont devenus très
rares coins ce qu'on accuse un déficit
de près de 50 % sur une année moyenne
les fontaines sont à sec depuis avril à
petit il est interdit d'arroser en
journée ou de laver sa voiture pour les
jours on constate simplement une
récession des moyens disponibles pour
alimenter en eau potable la ville d'ath
chaque litre d'eau qu'on économise ça
servira pour alimenter depuis longtemps
toutes les populations
grands consommateurs d'eau les
fabricants de fruits confiant dû réduire
leur besoin de 60 % en trois ans on est
obligé de se sensibiliser à ce problème
d'eau si on se sent sinistre à ce
problème d'eau on est con cerne dans les
années à venir les autorités sont
obligés de restreindre les activités de
faire exploser des coupures d'eau
aujourd'hui dans le vaucluse
même les orages ne suffisent pas à
combler le déficit en nous en tout cas
cette météo exceptionnelle n'a pas
empêché acheteurs et acheteuses de se
ruer sur les bonnes affaires pour le
premier jour des soldes
pour beaucoup c'est la période de
l'année où on s'offre quelques folies et
dans la bousculade les grands magasins
et les boutiques de luxe ont parfois été
prises d'assaut
j-1 beaumont et finet chassant les
soldes ça s'mérite entrer au compte
gouttes dans les boutiques de luxe mais
avant de faire des affaires il faut
patienter vraiment patent des vignes
trop long mais pense à beaucoup
pour repérer les marquis ont la cote pas
besoin de connaître leur cours en bourse
la longueur de la file d'attende suffit
à nous renseigner mais pour beaucoup les
soldes c'est le rêve
enfin accessible ça permet d'acheter des
trucs qu'on me bats normalement et
sans se prendre la tête sur le français
dans normal j'aurais pas le moins il
s'en trouve donc je profite pour
regarder les soldes c'est aussi une
affaire de spécialistes les mieux
organisés au fait le repérage
une semaine auparavant un impératif se
rendre disponible le jour j à la chaîne
les boutiques on maximise la journée
verte et ecône à disposition
repentant sera pratiqué on arrivera et à
ce petit jeu là certaines ont commencé
très tôt 8 heures du matin ouverture des
grands magasins ici cent trente mille
visiteurs l'équivalent d'une ville comme
aix en provence avec un objectif se
faire plaisir
c'est important quand vous les soldes
pour la lingerie oui c'est que je suis
très cher les surprofits en une journée
6 millions d'euros ont été dépensés ici
et pour être sûr de ne pas se tromper on
vient au couple pas forcément une bonne
idée de bon conseil et pour celles et
ceux qui n'ont pas encore eu le temps
d'y aller
pas de panique les soldes vont durer
entre quatre et six semaines selon les
départements
après la mort du petit sid ahmed
hammache tué dimanche d'une balle dans
la cité des 4000 à la courneuve trois
des quatre suspects ont été déférés
aujourd'hui au parquet de bobigny
nicolas sarkozy s'était rendu lundi
dernier à la courneuve il avait alors
parlé je cite de nettoyer la cité
il devrait y retourner mercredi nous le
confirmera dans quelques instants pour
rencontrer les jeunes et poser les bases
d'une politique de prévention
mais revenons à lenquête d'après les
premiers éléments l'auteur du tir mortel
aurait été identifié lindau des autres
hiboux tard à bobigny la garde à vue des
trois suspects est terminée la justice
pense savoir lequel d'entre eux est
l'auteur du coup de feu mortel
le scénario du drame commence à se
dessiner
on connaît maintenant l'origine du
conflit qui oppose depuis longtemps de
familles de la cité une aventure
amoureuse entre l'un des suspects est la
soeur des deux autres dimanche les deux
camps se croisent il y a des armes de
chaque côté au moins trois coups de feu
sont tirés une balle perdue atteint
mortellement sidi ahmed 11 ans
a la courneuve le choc est considérable
le jour suivant le ministre de
l'intérieur vient présenter ses
condoléances à la famille mais sa
démarche est mal perçue par certains
habitants du quartier je suis la réalité
le ministre promet de vite retrouver les
responsables de la mort de l'enfant mais
aussi de rendre le quartier plus sûr
les habitants de la cité des capus
maison comme les autres habitants de
france le droit à la sécurité
on va donc nettoyé au propre comme au
figuré la cité des 4000
nicolas sarkozy annonce une vaste
opération pour le lendemain quand les
policiers débarquent dans la cité ils ne
font aucune découverte de taille
trois des protagonistes de la fusillade
seront retrouvés quatre jours après le
drame
ce soir ils ont été déférés au parquet
de bobigny le principal suspect nie
toujours les faits nicolas sarkozy
bosphore et maintenant avec nous alors
d'avoir invité
on le voit il ne vous a pas échappé que
votre formule sur le nettoyage a pu
choquer et des critiques qui ont été il
est un peu partout en soi sabots à
l'assemblée nationale jean leonetti
mais non non juste un mot si vous
permettez sa choquer ceux qui n'ont
jamais mis les pieds dans cette cité ça
n'a pas choqué les habitants
j'ai passé deux heures réduit dans cette
cité et qu'est ce qu'ils m'ont dit les
habitants qu'ils n'en peuvent plus et
qu'ils ne comprennent pas pourquoi
l'état tolère ce que nous tolérions
nulle part ailleurs
alors ce qui pousse des cris d'orfraie
et qui sont choqués par le verbe
nettoyer je le confirme
mon devoir c'est nettoyer la cité des
4000 des trafics et des trafiquants
seuils de la jambe au terme mais bien
sûr et vous savez ce qui me choque moi
c'est que des individus soient capables
de tirer sur un petit garçon de 11 ans
et je n'ai pas à trahir de secrets mais
quand on voit le curriculum vitae des
gens que nous avons des frais de justice
j'avais promis qu'on arrêterait les
coupables nous en avons trois sur quatre
et je n'arrêterai que quand on aura le
quatrième j'avais promis qu'on irait
nettoyer la cité
tous les jours nous en voyons la police
pour obtenir des résultats parce que les
plus pauvres et les plus démunis nos
compatriotes
ils ont besoin d'insécurité ferry genre
tu ne rêves pas sain pour lequel
équivaut ya pu y avoir des critiques
c'est j'allais dire l'organisation des
choses le fait d'annoncer à l'avance une
descente de police menée durant il est
ce que parra est ce que c'est un gage
d'efficacité
vous voyez le décalage phénoménal dans
ce que disent certains responsables
politiques et ce que vivent les français
certains responsables politiques bien
nous calmer bien au chaud qui ne
connaissent pas les problèmes
d'insécurité sous choqué par une
expression que tout le monde emploie et
tout le monde comprend
moi je suis choqué par la mort d'un
enfant de 11 ans et je n'accepte pas
mais les armes dans la cité
ils ont retrouvé les tous les jours et
policiers qui tous les jours nous
retrouvons des choses mais ce n'est
qu'un début et je retournerai la semaine
prochaine pour rencontrer les jeunes et
pour essayer de mettre les bases d'une
politique de sécurité leur mot à dire
savoir pourquoi vous ne l'avez pas fait
dernière fois je n'ai pas fait pour une
raison simple c'est que je n'ai pas
l'intention de dialoguer pour rétablir
l'ordre
je veux qu'on rétablisse l'ordre et
aimerait vite seulement un dialogue pas
dans l' inverse
j'ai passé deux heures et demi là bas
j'y retournerai et la cité des 4000 les
habitants doivent le savoir ils auront
droit la même sécurité que les autres
c'est mon devoir je le ferai oui c'est
simple j'ai sécurité et après la
prévention mais ce sera quoi la
prévention parce qu'on dit m'en fous les
associations justement prévention elles
ont moins de moyens qu'avant extérieur
il ya une contradiction dans l'action
conserver la meilleure des préventions
c'est que les voyous qui trafiquent
sache et comprenne qu enfin maintenant
ils vont risquer quelque chose pour
qu'on n'arrive pas à la place d'armes
mais la peur de la répression la peur de
la punition comment voulez vous les
jeunes se lèvent tôt le matin quand ils
voient d'autres jeunes de la cité 10 les
trafics et de la drogue et gagner
beaucoup plus que quelqu'un qui s'est
fait tôt le matin moi je respecte la
france qui travaille et je n'ai pas
l'intention de me laisser impressionner
par les professionnels de la pensée
unique qui depuis 30 ans décrivent les
phénomènes de la violence respect bras
croisés et abandonne nos compatriotes
les plus exposés à des situations
intolérables quand karl on dit qu'il ya
une paix mise à sion des esprits c'est
une formule que vous trouvez ça déplace
chaque fois que l'on dit quelque chose
de bon sens on sera pas jeu monsieur le
pen
j'ai toujours combattu jean marie le pen
c'est moi qui abolit la double peine
c'est moi qui ai voulu que les musulmans
de france est une instance c'est moi qui
me bats pour la discrimination positive
et ceux qui ont profité de jean marie le
pen pendant les deux septennats de
françois mitterrand viennent me donner
des leçons aujourd'hui
alors quand je veux lutter contre la
voyoucratie contre les délinquants alors
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire donner des
leçons à tout le monde
oui j'ai vu que le récidiviste était bon
à la une d'un journal oui mon dieu quand
y'a un gosse de 11 ans comme a demandé
la famille de ce gosse qu'est ce qu'ils
m'ont dit qu'elle est monsieur sarkozy
arrêter les coupables
oui monde une deuxième chose
on en a assez que dans notre pays il est
coupable soit arrêté qui ne soit pas
plus là vous avez une obligation de
résultat en l'occurrence vous êtes
engagé mais françoise laborde j'ai une
obligation de résultat
là et ailleurs pourquoi ai-je été nommé
ministre de l'intérieur pour commenter
les phénomènes pour les combattre je les
combats très est par ailleurs une
section du 29 mai je veux le dire très
simplement c'est que les français ne
supporte plus d'avoir une classe
politique qui ont poids des mots que
personne ne comprend et un trop grand
décalage entre ce que vivent les
français et ce que nous disons alors
vous avez aussi secoué la magistrature
si je peux dire dans ce que vous avez
appliqué à tous un peu quand même je
rappelle les faits le meurtrier d'une
jeune femme nelly crémel tué d'une balle
dans la tête alors qu'elle faisait son
jogging la ferté sous jouarre
ce meurtrier présumé dont il était un
criminel déjà condamné à la réclusion à
perpétuité et qui avait bénéficié d'une
libération anticipée
vous avez dit alors que le juge
d'application des peines devraient payer
pour sa faute
et voici les réactions suscitées par vos
propos caroline gauthier fils jacent
le juge mise en cause par nicolas
sarkozy le voici alain and en poste au
tribunal de grande instance de colmar
houssen cas si le magistrat n'a pas
souhaité nous répondre
il réplique ce matin par voie de presse
aux propos du ministre de l'intérieur
c'est de la démagogie dit il monsieur
sarkozy ferait bien de réviser son code
de procédure pénale ce ton est
aujourd'hui celui de l'ensemble des
magistrats et en premier lieu le conseil
supérieur de la magistrature cette
institution est notamment chargée de
sanctionner les juges
le csm s'alarme des telles déclarations
inquiète des propos du ministre
l'intérieur qui ne sont pas respectueux
du principe de séparation des pouvoirs
et qui ne correspondent pas à la réalité
de ce qui s'est passé puisque ce n'est
pas une décision qui a été prise par un
juge
une décision qui a été prise par trois
magistrats sur avis conforme de
l'administration pénitentiaire du
psychiatre de tous les intervenants
face à l'émotion suscitée par les propos
de nicolas sarkozy jacques chirac nous
pouvait rester silencieux recadrage ce
matin avec ce rappel sous forme de
communiqué
le principe constitutionnel de la
séparation des pouvoirs et le respect de
l'indépendance de la justice sont
intangibles et essentielles à
l'équilibré et au bon fonctionnement de
nos institutions
j'en suis le garant de son côté
dominique de villepin rejoint le csm
mais on trouvera une porte à son
ministre de l'intérieur loi a été
appliquée mais en moins et c'est ça
l'esprit de responsabilité il faut
s'interroger aujourd'hui sur la loi
elle-même et c'est pour cela que j'ai
demandé au garde des sceaux de bien
vouloir très rapidement étudier un
projet de loi nous avons tous les
éléments aujourd'hui pour le faire de
façon à prendre en compte les impératifs
de la liberté conditionnelle ont
qualifié de populiste par la gauche et
une partie de la droite nicolas sarkozy
provoque non seulement l'ire des
magistrats mais pose aussi problème on
reste de l'exécutif avoir décollé
sarkozy réunir des faits cette remise en
liberté est effectivement une erreur
mais ce qu'il fallait parler de faute
parce que la procédure a été respectée
mais alors revenons au fait si vous
voulez
j'étais à l'enterrement de man crime
elle y avait à côté du cercueil sa fille
de 12 ans et son mari d'une dignité
remarquable
je suis représentant de l'état comment
vous dites à ce père et cette petite
fille que l'état a laissé un criminel
condamné par une cour d'assises
souveraine à la perpétuité
parce qu'il avait déjà assassiné treize
ans après ce monsieur est libéré et on
me dit monsieur sarkozy la loi est
appliquée n'y a pas de problème il est
libéré et il assassine une jeune femme
pour 20 euros dans des conditions d'une
sauvagerie inacceptable moi je suis
ministre de l'intérieur qu'est ce que je
dis à ces gens la loi est mauvaise la
lho alors il faut la changer
et combien de temps va-t-on tolérer
qu'un individu condamné à la perpétuité
parce qu'il a tué ressort très un prêt
pour re tués alors je demande plusieurs
choses la première c'est que les
conditions de l'application des peines
on est bien il n'y a pas que des
magistrats qui décident l1 3 normalement
une collégialité parfait et bien au lieu
de décider entre je propose une chose
qui est désormais systématiquement
représentants des victimes
et des associations de victimes après
pas des victimes directes des
associations de victimes
après tout madame laborde les victimes
ont peut-être leur mot à dire
lorsqu'on relâche des assassins des
criminels ou des délinquants
la deuxième chose je ne veux pas de
larmes entaché la sérénité de la justice
qui doit prendre un peu de recul par
raport et je vous rappelle pas le je
vous rappelle que ce qui est choquant
c'est qu'une femme était assassinée par
un récidiviste dans des accords la cible
pas autre chose
la deuxième chose que je veux dire c'est
que les multirécidivistes maintenant ça
suffit il faut prendre des mesures pour
que ceux qui ne comprennent pas qu'on
prenne enfin et je demande qu'il n'y ait
plus de sursis lorsqu'il s'agit d'un
multirécidiviste qu'il n'y ait plus
d'aménagements de peine lorsqu'il s'agit
de multirécidiviste c'est le disque au
bout exactement et qu'il y ait
comparution immédiate contient un
multirécidiviste parce que les policiers
et gendarmes vous savez en ont assez de
courir pour arrêter les mêmes qui
recommence piennes troisième chose quel
problème difficile de la responsabilité
et j'aimerais qu'on y réfléchisse
calmement la responsabilité des
magistrats magicien bien sûr parce que
là j'ai vu beaucoup de décisions et
déclarations corporatiste quand un
médecin vous au père et qu'il commet une
erreur d'appréciation avoir des juges
il est traîné devant les tribunaux et
les condamner quand un homme politique
se trompe il est condamné
quand un français se trompent dans sa
déclaration sans intention il doit payer
les conséquences
je voudrais poser calmement la question
est ce qu'il payait existait un pouvoir
le pouvoir des juges sans responsabilité
l'un d'entre eux a dit quelque chose de
formidable de très intéressant de jeu
bilger la responsabilité ce n'est pas
une malédiction
c'est une chance alors j'ai voulu poser
le problème parce qu'une erreur
d'appréciation qui conduit un meurtre
qui conduit à une famille dans le
désastre le plus total
qu'est ce qui est choquant que je pose
cette question ou que celle ci n'est pas
la bonne formule
pardon la faute est pas bonne formule
non mais parce qu une décision qui
conduit à ce qu'une femme qui fait son
jogging est assassiné vous appelez ça
simplement une faute
j'appelle ça un drame qui doit nous
appelés à réagir
et pour une fois a agi
les magistrats ont dit qu'on est fous de
réfléchir ça veut dire quoi qu'il faut
mais des instances que vous allez
travailler là-dessus avec pascal clément
parce qu'après tout c'est l'une garde
des sceaux comment vous envisager les
choses ça veut dire qu'au moins il faut
poser le problème et réfléchir à la
question
alors on me dit que je mets en cause
l'indépendance de la justice
mais c'est une plaisanterie j'ai mis en
cause quelle indépendance
je dis simplement que quand on se trompe
au point où se sont trompés ces trois
magistrats ça peut arriver il faut que
le conseil des ministres a dit le prince
des sanctions quand vous pensez que la
jurisprudence du conseil supérieur de la
magistrature s'interdit de donner des
sanctions sur une erreur d'appréciation
des juges le regarde et françoise aborde
dans votre journal il ya quelques mois
n'a parlé d' outreau où des gens fait
trois ans de prison pour rien dans votre
journal on a parlé de la faire pardon
pour dominique baudis
il n'y était pour rien on a brisé des
vies parce que deux prostituées ont fait
des déclarations invraisemblables et
bien permettez moi de vous le dire dans
le divorce qui existe entre la justice
et les français qui réalisa ya aussi le
sentiment que le français de base est
responsable et que le français qui n'est
pas de base n'est pas responsable et je
voudrais poser une question français qui
nous regardent
est ce que ce n'est pas le rôle d'un
responsable politique de poser des
vraies qu'elle s'élançait ce débat de
lancer ce débat et le scandale est ce
qui vient de la part de celui qui lance
un vrai débat on de ceux qui se sont
trompés
au point de se trouver dans la
catastrophe auquel nous sommes
confrontés et josiane dernière chose
c'est que j'étais au club président de
la république et annonce deux décisions
importantes qu'on revoie les conditions
d'application des peines et qu'on
travaille d'arrache-pied pour trouver
une solution sur les multirécidivistes
vous voyez j'ai voulu qu'on agisse
le gouvernement décide d'agir alors les
professionnels de la pensée unique
tous ceux qui parlent sans rien faire
depuis si longtemps et bien aujourd'hui
doivent s'inquiéter parce qu'on a décidé
d'agir
merci nicolas sarkozy s'il me voir ainsi
se rencontrer john farrell la
préparation du budget maintenant le
gouvernement s'oriente vers une
réduction importante que prévu des
postes de fonctionnaires de l'état
c'est essentiellement au ministère des
finances et dans l'éducation nationale
que les départs en retraite ne seront
pas renouvelés
ce qui portera à samy
la baisse des effectifs explications
agnès bolide policiers agents des impôts
salariés des ministères au professeur le
nombre de fonctionnaires d'état devrait
être de l'ordre de 2 millions 348 me en
2006 par rapport à cette année ce sont
5000 postes à peu près qui devraient
être supprimés contre 7000 en 2005 et
4500 en 2004 la réduction des effectifs
dans la fonction publique d'état devrait
donc continuer mais dans une moindre
mesure que ce qui était prévu par jean
pierre raffarin
les deux ministères les plus concernés
seront celui des finances avec 2000
postes non budgétés et le ministère de
l'éducation nationale avec 2500 emplois
en moins en revanche 3000 postes
devraient être créés dans la recherche
milan laboratoire 2000 à l'université
des chiffres encore non définitifs les
lettres fixant le plafond des dépenses
pour chaque ministère devraient être
envoyés ce week-end dominique de
villepin le premier ministre était
aujourd'hui dans les ardennes avec jean
louis borloo ministre de l'emploi et de
la cohésion sociale il a rappelé que le
nouveau type vos contrat première
embauche incluant une durée d'essai de
deux ans pourrait être étendue aux
entreprises de 20 salariés et il a
précisé qu'il y aurait pour le salarié
une véritable rémunération est une
véritable garantie il a également
rappelé qu'il ne voulait pas remettre en
cause le droit du travail
parmi les dispositions prévues par
dominique de villepin pour lutter contre
le chômage certaine mesure concerne les
seniors en permettant notamment de
cumuler sa retraite avec le maintien
d'une activité partielle des
dispositions qui sont déjà en
application au danemark où les seniors
sont incités à rester le plus longtemps
possible en activité pour financer les
retraites futures reportage vincent
fourcade et josé boulesteix c'est l'une
des toutes dernières recrues du zoo de
copenhague
key 56 ans a rejoint l'équipe technique
il y a deux mois après trois ans de
chômage
c'est bon lever tous les jours le matin
en une
mais aussi de ne plus être dépendant de
l'aide du gouvernement
vous n'êtes plus cher quand vous gagnez
votre propre argent embaucher des
seniors aux jours de copenhague cela
semble évident une priorité ici mélanger
les générations et ce sont même les
pensionnaires qui ont donné l'exemple
vous avez dit santigold la barre vous
avez un groupe et c'est important
d'avoir à la fois des bêtes âgées et des
plus jeunes vous devez avoir tous les
âges
si vous voulez que le groupe fonctionne
mais au danemark difficile de retrouver
un emploi passé 55 ans 10% des seniors
sont au chômage deux fois plus que la
moyenne nationale et le danemark tente
d'inverser la tendance car il n'y aura
bientôt plus assez de monde au travail
concrètement aujourd'hui qui est assez
d'actifs pour financer les retraites
mais dans quelques années ce ne sera
plus le cas aujourd'hui
il y a trois actifs pour deux retraités
et demain si rien n'est fait ce sera
l'inversé
et pour trouver du travail aux seniors
le danemark mise beaucoup sur les
seniors eux même prié de se regrouper en
associations locales l'état couvre tous
les frais et les chômeurs eux font à
tour de rôle le travail d'une agence
pour l'emploi
on appelle les sociétés pour essayer de
décrocher un rendez vous comme chez jean
coutu et pour expliquer quelles sont nos
différentes expériences et voilà
des seniors très efficace sur les 65
membres que comptait ce groupe la moitié
retrouver un emploi l'an passé et compte
bien le conserver jusqu'à l'âge légal du
départ en retraite 65 ans au danemark
six mois après le tsunami qui a ravagé
l'indonésie la thaïlande et une partie
du sri lanka et qui a causé la mort de
225 mille personnes dont 95 français la
procédure d'identification des victimes
restent difficiles 2000 corps n'ont
toujours pas été identifiés c'est cette
tragédie que vivent 27 familles
françaises qui restent dans l'attenté du
rapatriement de leurs proches jacques
cardoze et demi venu de sa fille par le
moindre indice depuis six mois elisabeth
zana attend toujours qu'on lui annonce
avoir retrouvé le corps de natacha
disparu en thaïlande
je trouve ça quand même très très dur si
vous voulez parce que on passe par des
moments on sait disant bon ils vont nous
appeler pour nous dire que ça fait quand
même six mois six mois c'est très long
et très très long natacha travailler au
sein d'une association de défense des
orques et des dauphins le 25
elle envoie un sms à sa mère elle venait
de plonger pour la première fois de sa
vie au large de koh phi phi sur cette
île où les secours et les recherches ont
tant tardé dès le lendemain
les autorités n'ont pu retrouver que les
effets personnels lors de la réunion qui
est iron man mars
quelqu'un est venu me donner une
pochette avec des documents ayant
appartenu net a charmé me disant rien du
tout ni uzal été retrouvée rien du tout
la petite pochette j'ai signé
et ce n'est qu'après que j'ai ouvert
pour trouver ce qu'il est dans un
sentiment d'abandon que connaissent
toutes les familles de victimes dans le
processus d'identification et long à ce
jour 27 des 95 victimes françaises n'ont
pas été retrouvés mais environ 2000
corps restent à identifier
six mois après la catastrophe elisabeth
n'a plus beaucoup d'espoir elle a adoré
la mer bon lamer la prise cet été
elisabeth zana repartir à s'installer en
thaïlande reprendre les activités de sa
fille une façon de se rapprocher d'elle
et selon le coordinateur des nations
unies la reconstruction des pays dévasté
par le tsunami pourrait prendre jusqu'à
dix ans malgré l'aide fournie par la
communauté internationale et quelque 11
milliards d'euros fournis ont permis de
nourrir des survivants financer les
aides médicales d'urgence bâtir des
abris de fortune
mais sur place et diverses organisations
humanitaires peinent à coordonner leurs
efforts la concurrence parfois
l'emportent sur le bon sens reportage
philippe rochot et sylvain viaut on voit
flotter leur drapeau sur les ruines des
villes dévastées
plus de 200 associations humanitaires se
partagent la détresse des survivants du
tsunami
la fabrication de bateaux de pêche est
souvent l'une de leurs principales
activités
lorenzi française act up par exemple
fait construire une dizaine de bateaux
pour des familles de pêcheurs
il a fallu négocier avec les autorités
mais aussi trouvé sa place parmi les
autres ong quand même beaucoup
d'indigènes et savent pas été facile
pour nous de trouver notre place traces
corps comme on avait besoin d'eux des
autorités pour nous montrer quelles
étaient leurs plans pour développer la
région
on a on a dû être trouvé notre place à
nous mêmes en coordination avec les
autres ong pour plaire aux pêcheurs
indonésiens des ong étrangères ont
préféré envoyer des bateaux comme cette
association du koweït mais inutilisable
ici la forme du bateau n'est pas adapté
au vent et aux vagues qui lie à issy il
bouge trop haut il ne peut pas affronter
cette mère les ong pourtant se
rencontrent régulièrement sous
l'autorité des nations unies ou comme
ici à l'initiative d'une association de
protection de l'environnement qui veut
harmoniser l'action des humanitaires
pour la reconstruction des organisations
souvent tendance à travailler dans leur
coin sur leur territoire ce qui fait que
certaines vont par exemple promouvoir un
programme de reconstruction en achetant
du bois sur le marché local même si ce
bois provient de d'achat de sources
illégales qui contribuent à la
dégradation de la forêt les ong des
marques bien sûr tout esprit de
compétition mais il est clair qu'elles
se stimulent entre elles au moment où le
pouvoir indonésien via seulement de
voter le budget de la reconstruction
elles ont déjà bien avancé dans leurs
projets c'est un procès extrêmement
douloureux qui s'est ouvert aujourd'hui
en russie sur le banc des accusés le
seul rescapé du commando qui avait pris
en otage plus de 1000 personnes dans une
école abaissement l'assaut avait tourné
au bain de sang 330 morts dont 186
enfants
trente et un terroriste tué et il n'en
reste qu'un pour répondre aux
accusations des mères reportage anne
consignes et eghezée qui lui dit je te
regarde nos repas szczesny mon fils
était un peu plus âgés ctoire je ne sais
pas comment ta mère a pu accoucher de
toi regarde moi dans les yeux quand vous
êtes arrivé ce jour là c'était bien
l'école votre objectif
je ne sais pas tu ne sers et un bien sûr
c'est ainsi à chaque audience comme
svetlana qui a perdu son fils unique
les maires de beslan viennent témoigner
mais aussi interrogé l'accusé ou même
les témoins convaincus d'être les seuls
à vouloir faire éclater une vérité qu'on
leur cache selon elle l'accusé ne
devrait pas être seul dans le box des
accusés
elles demandent des poursuites contre
tous les hauts responsables chargés de
gérer la crise de beslan ça c'est mon
fils le petit garçon est mort sa
grand-mère aussi à la maison et lina est
seul
alors quand il n'y a pas d'audience elle
retrouve les autres mères en deuil à
l'association qu'elles ont créés
je n'ai plus rien à perdre il me reste
personne alors je me battrai jusqu'au
bout tant qu'il me restera des forces
pour connaître la vérité revoir encore
et encore les photos des enfants 10 par
an huit mois après le drame la vire
profond qu'on aura des slams la douleur
de ces mères gêne ici elles peuvent
pleurer tout simplement et emma qui a
perdu ses deux fils et son mari trouve
une raison de continuer à vivre dans
cette affaire et n'a pas eu d'opération
pour le sauvetage de nos enfants ce qui
s'est passé c'est une opération
d'extermination des terroristes
et qui ce logo est responsable de cette
si mauvaise opération
le pouvoir les maires de beslan affirme
avoir demandé plusieurs fois vladimir
poutine de le rencontrer si leur requête
reste vaine distel elles iront à pied au
kremlin pour le voir en iran le second
tour de l'élection présidentielle s'est
ouvert aujourd'hui 47 millions
d'iraniens doivent choisir entre un
religieux modérés et ultraconservateurs
pour chef de l'état et pour la première
fois les résultats sont difficiles à
prévoir
ce soir il ya eu un report de la
fermeture des votes qui resteront
ouverts jusqu'à 22h30 dans le procès
lefort l'avocat général a requis 13 à 15
ans de prison aujourd'hui
il s'agit de ce père françois lefort
jugés depuis le 6 juin pour agression
sexuelle et viol sur mineure les jurés
se sont retirés en fin d'après midi pour
délibérer
dominique verdeilhan et sébastien
laffargue une décontraction
déconcertante
françois lefort vit peut-être ses
derniers instants de liberté si les
jurés suivent l'avocat général et le
prêtre médecin affiche sa bonhomie face
aux journalistes
c'est le premier enfant dont je me suis
occupé il ya en 1961
son étonnant françois lefort 13 à 15 ans
de réclusion criminelle ont été requis
mais l'homme n'envisage pas un seul
instant des suis un verdict de
culpabilité
après j'aurai beaucoup de choses à dire
j'espère l'image du héros s'est fissuré
insiste l'avocat général le sein le fort
est tombé il est le portrait type de
l'humanitaire pédophiles selon magistrat
son innocence est impossible à démontrer
reconnaît sa défense le doute doit lui
profiter ne jugeait pas sur le coup de
l'émotion
si l'émotion devient tel que l'on ne
résonne plus il ya plus de procès donc
il m'appartient à moi de dire l'émotion
existe mais il ya aussi des faits il ya
aussi une réflexion il ya aussi des
points d'interrogation ça ça n'est bien
sûr pas du domaine de l'émotion mais les
jurés doivent parce que c'est la loi se
déterminer une façon raisonnable
l'émotion créée par les dépositions des
victimes face aux explications
laborieuses de l'accusé vont
probablement pesé lourd au cours du
délibéré
françois lefort l'a bien compris je suis
épuisée dit il je voudrais exprimer ma
souffrance
les derniers mots du prêtre avant la
justice des hommes
la sphère pechiney le retour 17 ans
après le délit d'initié qui avait
éclaboussé des personnalités très
proches du président françois mitterrand
une nouvelle affaire pechiney pourrait
mettre en cause des milieux européens
toujours dans les mêmes circonstances
russell est déjà fourni une liste de
suspects et le pôle financier de paris a
ouvert une information judiciaire
demain à l'occasion de la traditionnelle
gay pride à paris des fédérations de
professeurs et parents d'élèves
défileront pour la première fois il veut
dénoncer l'homophobie qui sévissent dans
les lycées un sujet encore tabou fanni
au vernis et delphine parc linéaire ont
rencontré des enseignants et des élèves
victimes de cette discrimination
à 19 ans mickaël est un enfant de la z
il a déjà changé d'école à trois
reprises pourquoi pour fuir l'homophobie
les moqueries et les sarcasmes et b
petite femme [ __ ]
quand j'entrais dans un vestiaire en me
disais est ce que tu t'es amoureux
vestiaires en changeant de lycée pour
atterrir finalement dans les quartiers
chics
michael a découvert une autre forme de
violence ou en vers bâle - cru plus
insidieuse les gens n'osent plus venir à
vers moi parce que je suis homo ou quand
il quand il accepte finalement mon
homosexualité il ne définit ce que
partent à jeter de moins en moins
attention à ça mais la solitude est là
comme michael d'autres adolescents
découvert en même temps leur
homosexualité et l'homophobie des autres
ensemble ils militent sous la bannière
du mouvement d'affirmation des jeunes
gays et lesbiennes aujourd'hui il en
appelle à la vigilance des professeurs
que le plus efficace ce serait de
traiter les insultes homophobes de la
même manière que les insultes racistes
ou antisémites partir du moment où on
reprend un élève qui dit ça noir ou sale
juif
on doit aussi reprendre un élève qui dit
sale [ __ ] ce discours a été entendu la
fsu principale fédération de professeurs
et de parents d'élèves a décidé de
réagir
elle demande à ses deux cent mille
adhérents de lutter contre l'homophobie
en classe et sans tabou elle ne pas
laisser passer l'injure ça commence par
ça et puis il ya des choses tout à fait
concrète qui peuvent être faites par
exemple on peut évoquer cette question
dans ses cours quand le sujet se prête à
ça ne pas hésiter quand on parle d'un
auteur homosexuels il faut le dire
militants et professeur espère être
reçue au plus vite par le nouveau
ministre de l'éducation nationale pour
qu'à la rentrée prochaine dans tous les
établissements et règlements intérieurs
sanctionne enfin l'homophobie à
wimbledon amélie mauresmo s'est
qualifiée cet après midi pour les
huitièmes de finale après sa victoire
sur l'américaine shenay perry en deux
sets 6-0 6-2 en revanche gaël monfils
est éliminée sèchement par le croate
mario en teach en trois sets 6 3 6 3 6
ans vous voyez alors évidemment là la
victoire d'amélie d'amélie mauresmo
suivi par gaël monfils face au croate
mario en titre
basket et la victoire du français des
san antonio spurs tony parker 23 ans
c'est la deuxième victoire de parker en
nba le meilleur championnat de basket du
monde le français est déjà détenteur du
titre en 2003 avec la même équipe formé
à l'insep près de paris tony parker
avait été champion d'europe avec les
bleus en 2000 avant d'entamer une
carrière américaine forme de dépaysement
totalement différente celui que l'on
trouve pas très loin de la croisette de
cannes l'île saint-honorat c'est un peu
l'île aux moines
depuis le 5ème siècle une communauté
cistercienne y est installée elle se
consacre à la prière et à la méditation
au chant liturgique mais aussi à la
culture de la vigne et à l'accueil de
quelques candidats à une retraite
spirituelle dans un cadre exceptionnel
jean-jacques des fours et je vais me la
skipper de la clé de sol
alain croiser devant l'île saint-honorat
pratiquement tous les genres
la nature est reine il n'y a aucune
habitation pas de voiture c'est comme
c'était il ya 5000 ans et à part le
monastère ces vierges complètement
c'est paradoxal avec cannes qui est
derrière qui est une fournaise de deux
films festival de congrès de gens qui de
frime de fric
le fric et la frime ce n'est pas trop le
truc des habitants de l'île en
l'occurrence une communauté cistercienne
de 25
anne une communauté composée d'italiens
d'espagnols
enfin pour faire court d'enfants de dieu
c'est une caractéristique de la
communauté pratiquement depuis l'origine
au cinquième siècle saint-honorat qui a
fondé le monastère nokia et à seize
siècles rassemblait déjà des gens de
toutes origines de saint-honorat je
dirais qu'il avait bon goût le coin
qu'il a dégoté pour méditer est superbe
sur sa pelouse est croyante
oui absolument très croyante et vous
êtes devenus vos ressources et nos
ressources et puis surtout pour ma merde
comme un air est sur le départ et la 81
ans et j'avais voulu lui faire plaisir
et vraiment c'est pour un rpg très sain
elle est au paradis
un paradis où l'on peut faire retraite à
condition de respecter quelques règles
il ya des choses que je demande aux
hôtes pour qu'ils puissent vivre une
bonne moment chez nous la première chose
c'est le silence
la deuxième chose c'est les offices on
peut rester plusieurs jours on peut
coucher ici on peut rester au maximum
une semaine et chaque année pour faire
un peu de roulement sinon j'aurais
toujours la même personne ait le minimum
je demande de nuit justement pour
pouvoir rentrer un peu dans l'esprit
et pour entrer dans l'esprit dans
l'ambiance il vaut mieux aimer le style
monnaie qu'elle est vitale
l'important c'est qu'il n'y a pas eu
d'avancée mois il m'appartenait pas de
radio pour
comme si la ce pour le climat la partie
ancienne de l'abbaye normalement
interdite aux retraitants aux touristes
nous l'avons visité en compagnie du père
vladimir le père vladimir qui dans une
autre vie était médecin généraliste
qui si vous êtes dans le réfectoire qui
est la pièce où ne mangeant pied du
xiiie siècle
si comme moi le mot réfectoire vous
donne envie de manger et de boire
sachez qu'ici on fabrique un excellent
pinard il ya depuis plusieurs siècles
des vignes sur cette île est depuis une
dizaine d'années nous nous avons dix ont
professionnaliser la culture de la vigne
que le travail de la communauté pour
produire du vin que nous vendons et qui
permet à la communauté de vivre une
communauté qui grâce à dieu vit loin du
bruit et de la fureur
ce paradis sur terre comme les unes des
autres retraités qui parlent en même
temps si c'est ça on peut y aller très
vite
on peut y aller très vite on part a dit
oui et donc veillant à ce que ce ne soit
pas trop envahi et quand ils t'ont garde
toujours le carnet et la sérénité en
série
rassurez vous madame les moines veille
et jamais ils ne laisseront les
mécréants saccagé leur île préservée
ainsi se termine ce journal à suivre la
météo nathalie roux et qui reviendra en
détail sur le risque d'orage puis le
point route valérie maurice 25 ans pj 01
55 jours de l'année laurence piquet
demain midi face à l'image présentée par
paul nahon et bernard benyamin à demain
13h excellence en soirée sur france 2
soit